I want to ask maybe a deeper question
which is kind of about your opinion on
theories of everything in general which
is that you know do we need a theory of
everything I don't like to match the
growth here of everything I I think what
we need is the theory of quantum gravity
so quantum mechanics of space-time or a
theory of quantum space time and this is
needed because the current theories do
not explain what happens in certain
circumstances like what happens at the
very beginning of the Big Bang or what
happens in the interior of black holes
we would need that theory to really put
all these principles that we discussed
of the beginning 20th century together
if you call that everything everything
that we learned in the 20th century
general relativity and quantum physics